n'a pas oublié la brosse à dents
d'après des fringues confortable
ils savent que chez mac
quel intérêt jetez jamais vu comme ça
mon frère réunion famille escale pendant
la campagne
vous êtes d'où vous habitez en ville
oui on est juste parti pour le week end
permis de conduire s'il vous plaît à lui
qui était en voiture pas demandé qui
était au volant se contrôler son
identité
sinon depuis quand sadate votre petite
affaire nous avons engagé georgina et
walter pour s'occuper de mes parents
quand ils sont morts je n'ai pas eu peur
de me séparer
est ce que tu fais une devant ma fille
je vais arrêter de fumer
elle va t'en débarrasser paris cnoss
c'est bon je crois que ça veulent
apparemment il ya plein de fer qui sont
portées disparues dans le coin je suis
cool attend ça ne fait pas flipper ça
fait plaisir de voir un frenchie
tiens-toi pardon aux faucons se dire
qu'est ce que t'as aux éclats je sais
plus où ils sont rose foncé toit dans le
salon non non non de la bâtisse blanc je
pas remplies
gâchons pas la matière grise